Jase if we're here today to talk about
Game of Thrones in your role in it how
excited were you when you found out
you're on the series to start with so
many actors what went for the same part
as me as Pitt so I'm it was one of those
ones like what do they want what they
looking for I must have had to look on
Google we had to look up pip in the
books like a drawing of him and he had
point years like me and he had dark hair
he's kind of my build and I was like and
I found out Jr Martin soon as I saw my
as soon as he saw the video of me he was
like that's Pitt so I was I was
overjoyed when I got the part and I
couldn't stop jumping up and down really
because because I'm this is like the
biggest thing I've done in my career so
what's it like playing pip he's really
fun character to play because um I like
the bits between him and Grenn and Jon
Snow and Sam well you know pips kind of
like he's a kind of quiet one but when
he has when he has stuff to say he'll
just say it and then like him the things
with grin when the wing when grenzen
saying stupid you know it will be like
he will say something basically tonight
downgrade him a bit and then and then
gren will get angry and kind of like
chased me or ran around yeah run around
Castle black chased me or something and
so yeah playing p.m. we haven't seen
that much of people what he can actually
do so hopefully in season four which I
don't know if I'm in yet but I'm hoping
I am and because there's there's a few
things on the internet saying I'm going
to be back in season four so it's kind
of like home
my character will start getting bigger
soon so em you see what pips about so
what would you like to see pip develop
into do you think I'm kind of like well
one I would love to for him to be the
best swordsman ever because when he's
over that wall that's exactly what
you'll need you know just a bit more
funnier because there's so much dark
stuff in gaming friends you need you
need some light and lighting bits of the
of this series you know so I just like
I'm liking me I would like it to be more
more joking with grain and stuff just to
make it more uplifting you know because
there's so much so much going on in Game
of Thrones everyone's like oh no he's
gonna died who's gonna die who's gonna
die it's all about dying you know he's
gonna be totally different pip when he
goes obviously over the wall because you
know he's not going to be playing the
jokey you know he's really he's gonna
he's scared you know really going over
the wall knowing there's white walkers
over there knowing you could die so in
terms of action then you're talking
about sword fighting and stuff you'd
like to see 13 bit more of that you'd be
a good swordsman I think it would be a
great swordsman but he just needs a bit
more a bit more practice because it's
like when we had to rehearse the sword
stuff one was doing the Game of Thrones
we only only had like him we didn't
really have long to do it we had one day
with Buster who done with the batman's
and stuff like that the fight
coordinator and stunt man he he kind of
he kind of showed us how to use the
sword he showed us a few moves and then
it was like okay that's it it's like and
then the next day it was like okay we've
got a bit of practice and then then
you're on set and like okay did not real
metal swords but they were wood you know
and stuff like that by them if you don't
do it right you're gonna you're gonna
end up hurting someone's still you know
you mentioned some of the people that
you are on set with on the show you
mentioned kiss Harrington you're in
those well also there's John
badly somewhat our late exactly it so
how is it working with these guys and
the other people you're on set with as
well and it's just really seeing them as
well it's just like come half the time
that they're just sitting there just
looking around you know they like some
maize that they're on the show as well
and then you like sometimes you can see
that it's like yeah I'm still like that
you know but it's amazing John's amazing
mark Stanley who plays grain he's
amazing whoever missed out sad Samer
he's amazing
samwell's the comedian out of all of us
though everyone surrounded Sam and we
just like got an extra kick so he's so
funny the guys
the guy's a comic genius basically so M
he kind of makes the time go fast on the
set when it's was really cold and you're
just thinking about the cold we're just
laughing at his jokes and you're blind
yeah and he woke up you know but come
back but everyone yeah these guys are so
amazing so talented and I can't wait to
see more of them you know they're
amazing which of the stories that you
love following in Game of Thrones apart
from your particular one Joffrey
I love I love his kind of story but ya
don't like him as that character is
horrible guy but he's a lovely actor
beautiful he's nothing like he's how are
you portrays this character tell me a
little bit about working on location and
also the costumes that you are on Game
of Thrones as well how does that help
you kind of get into the character and
stuff yeah the location of course were
black it's kind of sit on it's in the
quarry in Belfast where is it certainly
it's you have to grab some major Hill
and then right at the top of the hill
you see this castle which you know life
you expect to see big cars big castles
on top of a massive hill we'vewe've walk
around and suffer and that's exactly
kind of how our cost for black is and it
looks real as well I mean when we're on
set you know like like the look of the
set the smell like I'm obviously you've
got rotting flesh you've got you've got
the pigs here it smells like a bit of a
farm mix we've
fire coal burning world yeah exactly
it's just amazing and the last time when
I went for back well the last time when
I went back for a season season free
there's all these new families of
spiders in Castle black like oh yeah
you've got loads of them they've made
their own houses you know it's just like
because it's just sat there like a lot
of sets get taken down put back up and
then but it's been there since season 1
up to now and it's still there you know
and you've got the big massive gates
know when you watch films with the big
Gator I wish I was in one of those films
and like I am you know and like it's
like it's like living the dream you know
in the fact that you know when you watch
movies and it's like I was in there you
know it's brilliant and so what else was
you talking about the the location the
costume Wow yeah the costumers was like
in season one is started off with like a
small amount of gear to put on and then
by the time it went on the story went on
you kind of got more padded and then you
had a cloak a heavy one back when it
when you're way down all day in it and
season free they kind of look a bit more
I must put season free--free a question
one and I was looking at emails are in
season ones and they look more like an
I've stepped hump in the ranks you know
it kind of looked like more Jon Snow and
season 3 then the season 1 yeah it's not
a spoiler okay you need someone's help
you can't pull it on yourself you can
only be trousers on
but like em you need someone else to
help you put the costume on and once you
finally got on - the only time you want
to go tall it you know it's like you
know but yeah the the costumes the
costume had a big change through yeah
that season one when I had that costume
and then season 3 so I know something so
it's different you know that even the
gloves look different you know
yeah so yeah I can't wait to see myself
in season things well then kind of
feeling you're stepping up because the
costumes getting a bit more elaborate
kind of like getting scared because I
know like the characters gonna be going
over the wall any moment soon we haven't
even seen the script I'm gonna seen a
script for that nothing they only send
you for example if I had gamer friends
next week to film and you fly over to
Belfast only this week I'll have the
script in my hand so they don't give you
a lot of time to learn you learn your
lines yeah exactly that week and see if
I was busy doing other stuff it's not a
lot of time to you know get your get
your character you know learn your lines
basically in the week how do you do that
what your what your tricks for doing it
tricks of learning lines just kind of
recording yourself over and over keep on
reading over the page keep on reading it
and then writing like 20 or 30 if time
you supposed to read it much more than
that but you kind of got a sense of what
the Lions are and then there's gonna be
a few lines which you don't know and
then you just pick up the things like
okay it's that and then you drum it into
your head it's that and then everything
start making sense of like how to learn
them and stuff like you got them in and
then another good way of learning once
you've learned them try and write it and
then try and match the write what you
think
what the lines is to match up the
scripts like write that lines write that
lines right and then you know if you
write it how you write is how you say
and think think and say it as well you
know so it helps you deliver the line as
well but other times it's just pull it
on record just just listen to it all day
long and just just let let that go over
you know and make that your like
sometimes you come home from a hard
day's work you put on the CD chill out
you just got that over you know you just
got that like the words words instead of
music you know and it really helped so
that's how I do it how do you mix it up
when you're doing because you said
sometimes you're working on other stuff
at the same time what we're doing so
from go-arounds how do you keep the
things kind of separate in your head and
the characters and things like that so
it's a really hard one because right
about now I've got like four different
things I'm doing and they're four
characters Toto to be totally different
from each other so it's kind of like in
one of the film's I'm doing at the
minute it's something like a comedy and
planer he's like a druggie hooligan
factory at the hooligan Factory he's
kind of he's kind of like I'm playing
like a druggie but it's not all about
I'm not trying to play him drugged
drugged up completely free I want him to
be having a bit of life to me and I'm
not just dragging soem and the
characters are why he's funny he tries
to be aggressive but he's not he's easy
he's an idiot you're not like that you
know and then the next film I'm doing
like straight after there I've got I'm a
really nasty real guy you know so it's
kind of like completely different to
that and completely different to the
nice peeping game of Thrones so it's a
really different ton of different things
so it's really hard but it's like um you
just kind of you gotta concentrate on
one job at a time because I can when I
got all these films it was like I've got
to read every script like different days
but what I found is like because I'm
doing a hooligan Factory I'm only going
to concentrate on the hoodie camp
actually as soon as that's done all my
lines are done I just got the actions
then I move on to the different script
which is vendetta starring Danny Dyer
and then I have to start learning the
lines of that so that's how I kind of
making it easy for me to understand what
this characters from this world dis
characters from this world and stuff
like that and after a long day of you
know learning lines or being on set you
know doing all your business and wearing
these heavy costumes and stuff for Game
of Thrones if it's that how do you relax
how do chill out how does Joseph Elton
relax a nice hot bath with candles
don't have to be weekenders by a nice
hot bath and a beer yeah it's been
lovely to speak TJ sir look forward to
lots more from you as well we look
forward to season three Anna and who do
the factory and all the other films to
in let me to meet you thank you very
much
you